oui sophie primas est-ce que vous avez
été convaincu par ce discours du premier
ministre pour sortir du grand débat
national
non je n'ai pas été très convaincu parce
qu'en réalité aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le temps des solutions c'était le temps
de l'autosatisfaction sur les conditions
de ce grand débat sur lequel nous avons
et l'ensemble des groupes politiques ont
des questions d'ailleurs mais c'était
plutôt un exercice d'autosatisfaction
sûr nous avons compris la france et
voilà les grands thèmes qui sortent peu
de choses sont en réalité sortie de ses
conclusions
votre réaction sur cette phrase
d'edouard philippe qui a un peu ému les
sénateurs edouard philippe a affirmé que
jamais dans la vème république
les collectivités n'avait eu autant de
moyens financiers qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
c'était une façon un peu provocatrice
évidemment vis-à-vis d'aborder le sénat
et d'aborder les sénateurs nous
connaissons depuis une dizaine d'années
des grandes difficultés financières au
regard de l'effort que font les
collectivités pour aider le pays à se
redresser financièrement et ses efforts
sont continus les dotations viennent de
tomber dans les communes il ya un grand
nombre de communes qui voient encore
baisser leurs dotations il ya des
contrats qui sont mis en place avec les
grandes collectivités qui n'ont de
contrat que le nom puisqu'il n'ya que
l'état qui signent et qui donne son
accord donc nous avons aujourd'hui des
grandes difficultés financières je
trouve que c'était une provocation
inutile alors sur la fiscalité le
premier ministre a annoncé qu'il y aura
des baisses d'impôts financer par des
baisses de dépenses publiques
est-ce que cela va dans le bon sens
selon vous bien écoutez si on dépense on
diminue la dépense publique et qu'on
arrive à diminuer
les impôts c'est exactement ce que nous
nous demandons aux républicains depuis
très longtemps
c'était même j'allais dire le sens même
de la de la campagne présidentielle de
donc on est très content que ce grand
débat est ouvert les yeux du premier
ministre et peut-être du président de la
république donc mais maintenant nous
attendons les solutions quand comment ou
pourquoi est on veut pas non plus qu'ils
nous racontent de mensonge puisque je
crois que dans les dépenses et dans les
impôts qui qui vont baisser on nous
annonce les impôts qui était voté et qui
en fait sont pas mis en application
comme la taxe carbone
donc ça c'est pas des baisses d'impôts
cd non d'augmentation